and joining us right now because man we
would love baseball memories new
baseball memories this this common
summer the question is we're gonna get
it from MLB network as well as Jason
stark joining us right now is none other
than from the athletic and from MLB
Network Jason stark joining us right now
how are you Jason rich I'm doing well
strange times but we're all healthy here
so that's good how are you well I'd love
to see some baseball this summer
what in the heck's happening right now
Jason is you and I are you know are
hearing how the NBA is gonna move
forward and the NHL has at least a plan
on what it would look like when they can
figure out the the where and when and
the NFL is ready to roll the question is
is is how baseball is so far afield from
that what where is everything right now
on that front well the vibe I'm getting
right now is they're determined to play
and if that means there's no deal then
Rob Manfred will just announce a
schedule I don't know if it'll be 50
games 52 games 54 games 48 games
whatever it is they'll announce a
schedule they'll announce player should
report June whatever that is will start
playing July whatever it is that's going
to be the deal all players must report
and look that's not a good way to go
about this but I that's what it takes
I'm more convinced than ever that that's
what would happen they would just
require players to play and they
wouldn't have a lot of choice so um
where do things stand right now then in
terms of negotiation yes sir well we I
mean we've seen this movie a million
times I'm tired of watching it but
there's no we're really March 26 they
came into agreement two and a half month
later and they can no longer agree on
what they agreed on and that just sums
up this
date of Labor relationship in baseball
you've got this situation where owners
are saying we're going to lose millions
and millions and millions of dollars
even if we play if there are no fans in
the stands and you have the union's
saying we don't believe that you're
gonna have to prove it well they're not
going to put it there this is not going
to happen and so you know like the basis
of conversation would assume that at
least they understand each other's
Prentice that's not even happening so
they're like there been a couple of
proposals swatted back and forth there's
there's just no basis for conversation
and it's it's really discouraging to
watch especially at this moment in
America of course it is Jason so the you
know if if baseball is saying okay we
have a stock gap and that stopgap is a
shortened season and that from what I
agreed would pay players 30% of their
salaries and baseball rejected the
players saying here's something twice
the size in terms of schedule that will
pay us 70% of our salaries well
obviously we're seeing what's in the
middle so why can't they get to the
middle well you know I think the essence
of it is this alright the Union made a
proposal on Sunday I I think they knew
that the economics would be rejected by
Major League Baseball but there were
definitely elements in that proposal
that were worth talking about but in
order to talk about it you'd actually
have to have a dialogue a conversation
and like I can think of a million words
to describe these negotiations
conversation is not one of them
just wear a tennis match it would be
like you hitting the ball over the net
at me and me looking at it going not
swinging at that MLB has not responded
and had you know I floated this 50 games
season idea but have never proposed it
and if
they don't plan to make a
counterproposal that's where we are I
mean I think look I think ultimately
baseball is gonna have to make another
proposal at some point but I can't
explain me why they've wasted another
week because I look at my calendar July
4th is four weeks from tomorrow four
weeks and that's the date by what I mean
by which what an 80 game season would
hit I mean that's what I'm saying here
is it and so when when is midnight
because you know that's usually when
these things you have to get done what
Jason stark here in the Rich Eisen show
when when do you think midnight is or is
even that up for interpretation that
debate as well how many games how many
games are you gonna play right it's only
a 50 48 54 games scheduled then you
don't have to start that tool all this
first right if you really wanted to play
a fairly normal half season starting on
July 4th made a lot of sense it was
never a firm date but it was a great day
to aspire to because you have your you
would had to stay to yourself for three
weeks
and what an opportunity that would have
been for this sport right we just look
we just came through two weeks ago more
people watch Tom Brady and Peyton
Manning play golf and watch the final
round at a PGA people so definitely
something to watch baseball could have
been the only sport playing for three
weeks but now they're a bad at a time to
do that I got in here in July 15th now
but who knows you should just start
doing the math rich three week spring
training okay subtract three weeks from
July the 4th then players need time to
travel so that's going to be more time
these teams are going to need time to
get their facilities up to these health
and safety protocols that's more time
players after they report would have to
be tested and then isolated for a period
of time I mean like they would have to
have a deal done by happy hour in order
to play a July 4th or
or else you're looking at a different
scenario but there's not gonna be a deal
until they actually start talking
Jason stark here on the Rich Eisen show
um and I guess based on you know the
economics you can't come up with a
schedule but we can at least come up
with what what what at least can we come
up with which is is what it would look
like what would what it do they at least
have an idea of what the you know the
the who would play who and where I mean
is at least that hammered out depending
on 80 games 70 games 60 50 I mean do
they at least have that somewhere yeah
there was there was a if there was an 82
game season there was a definite format
with that it would have been like
picking pick the Dodgers right the
Dodgers would have played every team in
the NL West 13 times and all the teams
in the AL West six times so three-game
series home and home if you're cutting
down to 54 or 48 or whatever it is I
like there would still be clearly an
effort to regionalize as much as
possible that's a lot easier in the East
than it is in the West but that would be
the goal to minimize travel as best they
could and they'll be now has a number of
different schedule modules that they
could roll out but they're there's so
many unanswered questions and schedules
just one of many okay Jason stark so
then you know I wanted an update and
your update here on June 5th 2020 is
that they're not even talking to each
other and and and everybody's
essentially screwing it up so what what
do you think here I mean what it what it
at some point we will get it but we're
at least gonna get 50 games right that
what we're gonna do and right think
it'll be somewhere in that range
okay there's no agreement and so okay so
what happens if Rob Manford announces
here's our scale
yep first of all the players wouldn't
have much choice but to show up and play
if they don't they be staging an illegal
strike in the middle of a labor deal and
that like that's not a good idea that
creates all sorts of legal issues and
others but here's the question if that's
how this gets done where the players do
anything besides play you think they
would talk to people like me on zone
after games before games I gotta meet
with sponsors I don't think they would
do anything except waited games they
wouldn't allow an expanded postseason so
that would cost baseball revenue there
would be nothing but acrimony there
would just be baseball games and then of
course that set would set the stage for
the labor deal expiring in a year and
that just looks more and more like Labor
Armageddon
well what about this Jason what about
certain players who are crucial to their
team's chances not saying that we're
we're not playing because I'm pissed
about the labor agreement
I'm not playing because I'm I'm
concerned about my health so I'm not
playing I mean how all right now how
would that be handled yet yeah that's a
really interesting question I wrote
about it a week or so ago actor Robin
amp it said on CNN that they wouldn't
force anybody to play who didn't feel
safe playing and this should be part of
the negotiations and I think if it were
you'd have three different classes of
players you'd have first off a group of
players who would fall under high risk
their cancer survivor' survivors or
they've had a heart issue or they have
diabetes whatever you know they would
clearly be at risk I think those players
would have the right to opt out and get
full salary and service time I think
that would it would almost have to do
that but then the other two categories
are very problematic one is all right
you're not high risk but you have a
family member who's high risk and that
would seem like they would fall under
the same category but how are we
defining family members suppose you just
had aging
parents grandparents whatever living
with you who would be high-risk would
that be enough to qualify and then you
had the Union would want that third
category of player to be just somebody
who says we don't feel comfortable
playing what the Union proposed over the
weekend for that player was or that
player wouldn't get paid but we'd get
full service time so hold on one minute
you think the Dodgers would be in favor
of Mookie Betts sitting at the season
and he becomes a free agent no way
what a fun negotiation that would be so
it would be best if this were negotiated
out I'm guessing if it's just Rob
Manfred announcing here's the schedule
they would say high-risk players fall
under one category everybody else has to
play what a hot mess Jason stark man I
hope everybody pulls this thing together
because you're right three weeks of just
like baseball and seeing it and and then
there's the whole issue of protocols and
figuring out I mean my gosh I hope it
can get figured out and I appreciate you
joining me to hash it out Jason thank
you
hope you're rich thank so much that's
Jason stark at Jason s T on Twitter I
follow me you should too hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here